I
the individual then carries out the law
of his heart this becomes a universal
ordinance and pleasure becomes a reality
which absolutely conforms to law but in
this realization the law he has in fact
escaped the individual that directly
becomes merely the relation which was
supposed to be got rid of the law of the
heart through its very realization
ceases to be a lot of the heart for in
its realization it receives the form of
an affirmative being and is now a
universal power for which this
particular heart is a matter of
indifference so that the individual by
setting up his own ordinance no longer
finds it to be his own consequently what
the individual brings into being through
the realization of his law is not his
law on the contrary since the
realization is in principle his own but
it actually is for him him and alien
affair what he brings about is merely
the entanglement of himself in the
actual ordinance an entanglement in it
moreover not as a superior power which
is only alien to him but one which is
hostile by his act he places himself in
or rather posits himself as the
universal element of existent reality
and his act is supposed to have even
according to his own interpretation the
value of a universal ordinance but he
has thereby freed himself from himself
he goes on growing qui universality on
his own account and purges himself of
his own particularity the individual who
wants to recognize universality only in
the form of his immediate being herself
does not therefore recognize himself in
this free universality while at the same
time he belongs to it for he it is his
doing this doing therefore has the
reverse significance it contradicts the
universal ordinance for the individuals
act is supposed to be the act of his
particular heart not a free universal
reality and at the same time he has in
fact recognized the ladder for his
action has the significance of positing
his essential being as a free reality
that is of acknowledging the real world
to be his own essential being
in paragraph 372 we see what happens
when the individual attempts to apply or
externalize through action the law of
the heart that has been motivating them
which we saw in the previous paragraph
also involves a certain kind of pleasure
we're going to see that assume an
important role in this paragraph and a
few other Paris following but what's
going to happen is a kind of
estrangement or alienation and Hegel
doesn't use that term at this point
instead he talks about entanglement and
contradiction but that's really what's
happening the individual the self
conscious rational human being who is
motivated by what we've called at this
point the law of the heart is going to
act and that act is going to have as
Hagel calls it the value of a universal
but it's going to run into another law
and we've got it you know capitalized
here because of the law of the world of
actuality which could be understood if
the person was ready for it at this
point as a free universal reality but
the person isn't up to that and so winds
up having to resist it in certain ways
to go against it who to try to tear it
down so Hagel says the individual
carries out the law of his heart and
this can happen in a multitude of
different ways depending on what the law
of the heart is bidding that individual
to do and this can vary from individual
to individual situation of situation
novel in which this is occurring to a
different novel or movies for us love
songs right and he says this becomes a
universal ordinance now the word that's
being translated as ordinance here is
one that we've seen in previous
paragraphs as order or as you know the
sort of law that the person is running
into
ordinal at ordinary means something like
an order but understood in terms of
arrangements articulation of things and
so they're running into a world this is
again what Hagel had called earlier
ethical substance this this tissue of
relationships of mores of customs of
people doing things in relation to other
people so it says this becomes a
universal ordinance and pleasure becomes
a reality which absolutely conforms the
law starts out pretty promising right
not only get you do you get to have your
pleasure which is not just the pleasure
in you know enjoying physical things
like saks or drugs or or I suppose rock
and roll or things like that but it's
got a higher purpose remember in the
past paragraphs we talked about this
pleasure as being a greater satisfaction
because it's it's what's benefiting
humanity right and so you look like you
get to have it all but we don't so he
says in this realization the law has in
fact escaped the individual there's the
estrangement or alienation that's taking
place there says it directly becomes the
relay early the relation which was
supposed to be got rid of what was the
relation that was supposed to be gotten
rid of well this this law which is not a
law of the heart but which should be a
law of the heart the law of the
community the law of the ethical
substance now that can't be the law of a
heart because it's not as if the
community has that sort of we're not
going to say a physical heart of course
but that sort of metaphorical Center and
remember for Hegel this is not talking
about in a sort of augustinian sense
where the heart is the very core of the
human being no this is the locus of
feelings of effect of something that is
purely subjective
and arises and can produce principles
but is not itself we might say Prince
the pulled so he goes on and he says the
law of the heart through its very
realization through you know not just
having it as a kind of inner guidance or
a set of ideals but actually trying to
put it into play realizing it in in
actuality or in reality the law of the
heart ceases to be a law of the heart in
its realization he says it receives the
form of an affirmative being and now
becomes a universal power of mocked
right a universal power for which this
particular heart is a matter of
indifference so that the individual by
setting up his own ordinance no longer
finds it to be his own in a way what
this means is that when the law of the
heart is externalized when it is enacted
what it is produced in action when its
universalized in a way it becomes too
successful it becomes something that no
longer just belongs to and expresses you
know when we talk about somebody owning
right we talk about something owning a
cause I realize that I need to resist
this particular kind of injustice and
suddenly I find myself not only being
not the only person doing that but that
my way of doing it might have just been
a preliminary way other people are doing
it better they have a fuller conception
of what's going on maybe I myself am
turning out to be the one who is
perpetuating a different kind of
injustice and we could come up with all
sorts of examples of this sort of
dynamic playing itself out in history
including in our own recent history so
the law that the law of the heart
started out with and then externalized
becomes no longer a law of
that heart no longer a law of that
individual no longer there's like he
says it's now a universal power so it
says consequently what the individual
brings into being through the
realization of his law is not his law on
the contrary since the realization is in
principle his own but it actually is for
him an alien affair this is where we get
to the rest of the ordering right
because there's this eight process of
alienation of losing of becoming
different going on he says what he
brings about is not the realization that
he thought it was going to be but merely
the entanglement of himself in the
actual ordinance and entanglement in it
not as a superior power which is only
alien to him but one which is hostile so
what we have going on here now is a
conflict between the individual and the
law or the ordinance the ordering which
there entangled with how are they
entangle entangled is a nice way to put
it they can't completely pull away from
it because part of their very meaning is
bound up in it and bound up also in
resistance and critique of it right or
at least opposition to it they also
can't get away from it because they're
still drawn to it by and Hagel is not
talking about this here but we should
think about this by the play of desire
for that lost pleasure think back to
earlier on even before we got into the
dynamic of pleasure and necessity the
introductory parts of this where the
individual unmooring him or herself from
the matrix of ethical substance now is
lacking and needs to make up that lack
that's what the law of the heart
was supposed to be supplying but instead
the law of the heart is reduplicated
that within the person in relation to
you know again what we could call
ethical substance so if we go on he says
by his act he places himself in or
rather posits himself as the universal
element of existent reality so that's
that's over here right the law of the
heart was supposed to be better than the
previous dialectic because the
individual had incorporated whatever was
going on with fate or necessity into him
or herself and that's what the law of
the heart was supposed to be but it
unfortunately it's immediate it's not
yet as Hagel pointed out disciplined so
he treats himself or herself as the
universal element of existent reality
his act is supposed to have even
according to his own interpretation the
value of a universal ordinance that
that's what it's tending towards by
acting it's supposed to be connected
with this universal ordinance but the
individual has thereby freed himself
from himself now Hagel points out two
different ways in which things could go
here he does he doesn't make the
transition as clear as we might like he
says he can go on growing qui
universality on his own account and
purges himself as his particularities
that's one possibility that's not a
possibility that's going to be realized
at this point that is going to be
realized later towards the end of this
and moving into the next main dialectic
that of virtue in the way of the world
it's also going to carry through into
the spirit section here and other other
parts of the reason section and the
religion section but that's not what's
happening right now instead they're sort
of you could call it a hardening or
retrenchment of the individual on that
side as opposed to the world order on
the other side so he says here we go the
individual who wants to recognize
individual universality only in the form
of his immediate being for self does not
therefore recognize himself in this free
individuality what was that the ethical
substance well at the same time he
belongs to it why because it is his
doing this is not Anna solipsistic way
we're like the individual realizes he's
created everything and everything is
dependent upon his desires wishes no
it's not like that but by engaging in
action motivated by the law of the
harder expressive of the law of the
heart he has contributed to this order
that he finds so oppressive and
alienating so he says the doing
therefore he has the reverse
significance the doing contradicts the
universal ordinance it's supposed to be
establishing the universal ordinance
instead his or her action is
contradicting it he says goes on he says
the individuals act is supposed to be
the act of his particular heart not a
free universal reality so where is the
contradiction it's we could say it's
happening in two ways I think it's
probably best to think first in terms of
the intention the motivation of the law
of the heart as opposed to the free
universal reality and they are in
contradiction the contradiction is
happening in the locus of the Act which
is being made to serve a dual purpose
you could say insofar as the individual
wants his or her act to matter as an
expression of the law of the heart it
cannot just be this free universal
reality under
in terms of the mores the laws following
along getting going along to get along
as we say there has to be something
special something particular something
unique something eigen that is this his
own her own right where they can say
this is my contribution to the great
progress of human realization right this
is a you know a dynamic that we see
occurring many times and again in many
ways even in our own present so he says
the individuals they act is supposed to
be the act of his particular heart and
at the same time he has in fact
recognized the universal reality why
this action has the significance of
positing his essential being as a free
reality of acknowledging the real world
to be his own essential being we don't
have a resolution of this contradiction
at this point and we have to see now
where Hagel is going to go are we going
to find out that there is some sort of
reconciliation happening or are we going
to have to move away from this
understanding
the individual as by the principal of
his action determined the more precise
way in which the actual universality to
which he has attached himself turns
against him his deed qua actuality
belongs to the universal but its content
is his own individuality which as this
particular individuality wants to
preserve itself in opposition to the
universal it is not any specific law the
setting up of which which would be in
question on the contrary the immediate
unity of the individual heart with
universality as the thought elevated
into a supposedly valid law that in what
is law every heart must recognize its
own self but only the heart of this
individuality has placed its reality in
its deed which expresses for him his
being for self or his pleasure the deed
which is the deed is supposed to have
immediately the status of a universal
that is to say it is in truth something
particular and has merely the form of
universality the particular content of
the heart as such is supposed to have
the status of the universal consequently
others do not find in this content the
fulfillment of the law of their hearts
but rather that of someone else and
precisely in accordance with the
universal law that each shall find in
what is law his own heart they turn
against the reality he set up just as he
turned against theirs thus just as the
individual at first finds only the rigid
law now he finds the hearts of men
themselves opposed to his excellent
intentions and detestable
paragraph 373 also displays what at
first appears to be rather paradoxical
dynamic going on which again this is the
dialectic at at work it's not really so
paradoxical if we disentangle it but
what this is about where where the
paradox resides is that in winning the
person expressing the law of the heart
loses right and how do they do so by
being in a certain sense to successful
again what do we mean by that well they
they manage ultimately to make the law
the external ordering of the world make
that change in some way to conform to
the law of their heart they're able to
express this law of their heart some
ideal some sentiments some some feeling
about how things ought to be changed how
things ought to be different how things
ought to be better they're able to do
that and then what happens other people
come along and they express a different
point of view they're like that well
that is not my law of my heart you're a
tyrant now Hagel doesn't use the word
tyrant here although he will very soon
in the next paragraph but why would that
happen well it has to do with the way in
which this is being realized so he says
the individual has by the principle of
his action determined the more precise
way in which the actual universality to
which he has attached himself turns
against him so what we've got here at
the very beginning is the conflict
between the individual motivated by
trying to express the law his heart and
the universal the law with a capital L
we might say in all caps the law which
is a ordering and it supposed to him
right and there's a hostility there as
we saw in the previous paragraph so how
does this happen well I had mentioned
that there is within the deed or the
action itself within the doing the
attempt to externalize right there's
already a kind of splitting going on
it's not just motive over here and
reality over here in the action itself
it can be looked at in multiple ways
because the action itself is in fact
complex action is where realities
collide and coincide you might say so he
says his deed qua actuality belongs to
the universal a little bit later he's
going to talk about it is being
Universal inform whenever we act this is
something that Hagel pointed out to us
much earlier in the observing reason
section whenever we act we are engaging
in something that is significant and
it's significant because there are
universals involved so you know doing
this is waving a hand right you
understand it is waving a hand it's not
a completely particular out of the blue
no connection of what anything
whatsoever sort of action it's
understandable and describable in
universal terms on the other hand the
content as he says the area the the
content is his own individuality which
as this particular individuality wants
to preserve itself in opposition to the
universal when we are acting so for
example the waving my hand which now is
a different action right I don't have
the book in my hand I'm demonstrating to
you something that was the point of my
action that's my particular individual
motivation you yourself could
appropriate that in part because it is
universal in form and use it for your
own example pick it up as a mannerism I
want to imitate dr. Sadler today for I
don't know Halloween or something like
that he waves his hand a lot and we
could go on and
on and on there are myriad ways in which
particular individuals can supply a
content to an action that makes it
different even though it's the same
action universally same action in form
as another action that makes it
different from that action this is where
motive particular motive can come in and
what's the particular motive at this
point I'm going to stick it to that
universality they're not going to tell
me that I don't get to express the law
of my heart and they succeed so he goes
on and he says it's not any specific law
the setting up of which would be in
question on the contrary the immediate
unity of the individual heart with
universality is the thought elevate it
into a supposedly valid law that in what
is law every heart must recognize its
own self let's look at that a little bit
more closely he says it's not any
specific law the setting up of which
would be in question so we it's not just
a particular law a particular cultures
laws or mores or whatever that presents
a problem it's the very conception of
law understood through this law of the
heart so he says the ending of the
individual heart with universality is
the thought that in what is law every
heart must recognize its own self now in
saying that it's trivial for oneself
because one's own heart set up the law
right what about other people are they
going to as we say get on board are they
going to identify their heart with this
law that this person derives let's go on
a little bit further
he says but only the heart of this
individual has placed its reality in its
deed which expresses for him his being
for self or his pleasure he's getting
something out of it that doesn't
vitiated it by the way it doesn't make
it no longer in law or no good or
anything like that but it is his law and
he enjoys the very fact that by giving
this law by behaving in a certain way he
or she is helping humanity righting
wrongs making the world a better place
can you get what we call buy-in from
other individuality 'he's they should of
course go along with it right because
he's got a good motivation he has a good
heart or she has the right intentions
the best of intentions other people can
say no I don't really like that that's
that's good for you you derive
satisfaction from that you derive
pleasure from that I derive pain I
derive anger I derive cognitive
dissonance whatever we want to say it's
not helpful for me sometimes people say
so he goes on and he says the deed is
supposed to have immediately the status
of a universal that is to say it is in
truth something particular and it is
merely the form of universality like we
pointed out before its actuality is the
form of universality so he says the
particular content of the heart as such
is supposed to have the status of a
universal the heart is hungry for
universalization we might say for making
it at the heart writ large so he goes on
and he says consequently others how to
others see this they do not find in this
content the fulfillment of the law of
their hearts but rather that of someone
else now notice it's the content the
particularity that presents a problem
they may be able to get behind the
universal
but the content matters where it's
coming from matters the fact that this
is an immediate effective subjective
basis matters to them they want to have
the ability to have to say yes I go
along with this ride or not so he says
others do not find in this content the
fulfillment of the law of their hearts
but rather that of someone else the law
of another heart see it's not just
enough to say when we're talking about
this law of the heart thing to say oh
well there's a law of the heart and you
know Hagel felt it and so we just have
to follow along because you know he did
the feeling already and you know or
Russo or pick whoever you want in the
present right this this person who
really has a tender heart he or she
decided it for us know if it's going to
be a law of the heart I have to have my
own law of the heart and so do you and
so if there's some other person who's
deciding with the law of the heart
consists in and imposing it on us like a
rule like a law like an ordering we're
going to say hey screw you I don't want
that that's not me I can't identify with
that and so Hagel says precisely in
accordance with the universal law that
each shall find in what is law his own
heart they turn against the reality he
set up just as he turned against theirs
theirs was the universal that we had
been looking at before the ordinal right
the world order it's mean think about
what we're talking about here let's make
it a bit more concrete we have a person
who say has a very highly developed
conscience a great sense of empathy they
see some sort of disadvantage occurring
to people within the community that
strikes them as is wrong and other
people
go along with it and even perpetuate it
and say that it's okay and perhaps it's
deserved right and this person through
force of personality and because the law
of the heart is a pretty strong
motivator they're able to bring about
some sort of societal change through
their action could be just you know
picking that person up and saying you
matter don't listen to those jerks out
there you do in fact matter you have
human dignity you you know whatever
we're going to say could be legislation
it could be activism could be you know
the activism of the pocketbook it could
be all sorts of things once they're able
to rework the universal order originally
they were fighting against universal
order that these other people were part
of now they have replaced the universal
order with something that is their heart
writ large the other people are just as
you know justified because they are
equally subjectivity they are equally
people in saying the law of your heart
does not express our hearts and the
universal order that you've established
now turns us into particulars who aren't
happy about the fact that we're not
represented here anymore Hagel says well
that's that's to be understood that does
come about because we all are people so
he goes on and he says just as the
individual at first finds only the rigid
law now he finds the hearts of men
themselves opposed to his excellent
intentions and detestable this
introduces a lot of we could say
psychological discomfort any idea of
pleasure has been lost now rather it's
been replaced by grief pain bewilderment
why can't these people see how much I'm
trying to do for them I'm the good guy
and the world order was the bad guys so
why aren't the struggling humanity
suffering humanity getting on board with
my program
you